the amount of rubbish in Cairo is quite
staggering the bulk of it comes here an
area known as garbage city and it's
dealt with by the Zabaleen an army of
unofficial workers who recycle more than
80% of the rubbish they're collecting
making them the top recyclers in the
world even so the amount of rubbish is
overwhelming look at this Cairo skyline
there are piles and piles of rubbish
stacked up on the city's rooftops the
rubbish and the huge amount of plastic
waste ends up everywhere so many of the
tributaries and irrigation canals
leading to the River Nile are utterly
clogged with every type of scrap
imaginable this could well be the future
nightmare scenario of all inhabited
areas along the length of the Nile the
canals seem to have become dumping
grounds as the city's population grows
and the rubbish it's generating grows
with it that leads to entire waterways
being clogged and it will have a
devastating effect on agriculture on
fish and on the livelihoods of millions
of people fish have been a staple part
of the Egyptian diet since the days of
the Pharaohs and the fishing industry
employs hundreds of thousands of people
in the country we wanted to know just
what impact all this plastic was having
so we turned to a top scientist to do
the first research into the prevalence
of micro plastics in Nile fish
dr. Farhan Khan examined a batch of fish
from the Nile and two of the most common
in more than three-quarters of them he
found microplastics when all the samples
were laid out on the bench
you could go through them and seek
really quite big bits of plastic and you
could see really quite big bits of
plastic on a lot of the samples
many of the fish had ingested more than
one piece of plastic and dr. Khan was
focusing only on the larger sections if
anything we probably underestimate
what the problem is that you know the
fact that we've detected visible
plastics ones that you could take
pictures of with your phone for example
so we're not seeing the smallest size
Ranger so that estimate we make of
around 70 to 80 percent is probably on
the conservative side Egyptians are very
precious about the Nile and citizens
have been jailed in the past for
doubting its cleanliness but we found a
great many are worried about the plastic
in the world's longest river which feeds
into the Mediterranean well I do get
frustrated that no matter what I do
personally it's so hard to change
people's habits but people have bigger
problems in their everyday life of just
getting by they don't understand the
damage they do by chucking stuff away
our research is a startling indication
of just how big the problem of plastic
in Nile fish is this is a river at risk
of being suffocated by plastic and it's
only getting worse
Alex Crawford Sky News in Egypt